the war in neighboring Ukraine is making
EU membership a high priority for these
moldovans
a thousand people attending this rally
called by President Maya Sandu
moldovans are Europeans and in seven
years we must become full members of the
European Union we the people of this
country decide now irrevocably that
Moldova raises its head and proudly
moves forward to the European Union
[Applause]
Moldova applied for EU membership after
Russia's Invasion last year a move
welcomed by European Parliament
president Roberta metzola
choose Europe
and Europe will welcome you with open
arms and Open Hearts demonstrators are
calling on the country's Constitution to
be changed to formally recognize their
desire to be part of the EU
I believe in a European Moldova and wish
for a future with Advanced Economic and
socio-political Development we're a
little behind but we'll slowly catch up
and stand on par with Europe
integration in the European Union should
bring us well-being better jobs
happiness for children and Moldova full
of success so that the most beautiful
things in the world can be here in the
Republic of Moldova
but not everyone in this former Soviet
Republic wants to be a part of the EU
the pro-eu March was counted by rival
anti-eu marches in other cities
president santu accuses the Kremlin of
fueling anti-government protests and
propaganda while Russian troops are
stationed in the Breakaway region of
transnistria
but Moscow denies meddling in moldova's
affairs